richard feynman is a hero to millions
around the world from physicists to
ordinary people like bill gates thomas
frank
and others he inspired me in more ways
than want to become a physicist i even
style my hair to match his the man who
said the first principle is you must not
fool yourself what if he may have fooled
the whole world through a colossal fib i
think i got three patents i don't know
what they are anymore three patents have
my name on it did feynman forget did he
fool himself or
was richard feynman a liar
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
i read all of his books i read all the
books about him and i even went and
tried to delve into some of the work
that he did as a graduate student
completely over my head whoosh he was so
far ahead of his time it seemed like he
came from another planet and i think i
can safely say that and nobody
understands quantum mechanics
in one of his books this one surely
you're joking mr feynman he allegedly
received not one not two but maybe as
many as three patents
patents about
advanced technology stemming from his
work in the manhattan project
now was he lying about these patents
because it turns out we can't actually
find any records of those patents and
these patents if true would be
colossally important they would rely on
all the technology that he produced as a
young scientist now during those times
he was renowned for his exploits even
encouraging the eye of the government
feynman even drew the attention of the
federalist when he cracked many of the
safes containing the nuclear secrets
that the scientists including
were uncovering and unraveling in almost
record time during the early part of the
1940s the race was on to build an atomic
weapon it was encouraged by none other
than albert einstein this technology
could result in improvements to things
that we take for granted transportation
energy generation millions of such
releases of energy that make up this new
source of power most patents don't ever
make a penny let alone the sumptuous
sums that feynman was perhaps
envisioning
he allegedly sold his patents for a
dollar to some military g-man but again
we have no records of this
now his books are best sellers and
inspired millions around the world he
was a gifted lecturer and according to
bill gates he is the best teacher that
bill never had such a great example of
how he could explain things
in a fun and interesting way feynman
explained the strange theory of light
and matter known as quantum
electrodynamics that governs electric
and magnetic fields and their attraction
and their repulsion from one another
he invented
so-called feynman diagrams the feynman
diagrams are an incredibly powerful
technique for representing the
interaction between particles and fields
the feynman diagram just consisted of a
set of straight-line tracks which were
supposed to be individual particle
tracks
and joined at vertices where
two or three lines would intersect
and each vertex corresponded to an
interaction and each straight line
corresponded to a particle track and
then you had propagators which were
telling you the probability amplitude
for the particle to move from a to b and
then instead of a path integral you had
just a sum over the propagators
and that was supposed to give you the
answer and the amazing thing was that it
did that the amazing thing was that this
very simple
diagram
method gave you the right answer he
discovered the underlying cause of the
challenger disaster against all odds
coming to the conclusion that it was
nasa's fault for pushing a launch too
soon on a cold fateful frigid january
day though had many many warnings that
there was something wrong it wouldn't be
enough that he just came up with the
idea of nanotechnology dr feinman
clarified the topic that there's a
plenty of room at the bottom which means
that the critical point is scale of
quantum computing this particle's moving
around at temperature t so it pushes on
the walls it has pressure it has all the
thermodynamic quantities but it's only
one molecule he didn't have to fib
he already had his nobel prize why would
he have to boast about patents that he
never had as he said the first principle
is you should not fool yourself the
second principle is that you are the
easiest person to fool and surely you're
joking mr fineman he talks at one point
about how all the scientists were asked
to write down any idea no matter how
potentially obvious it could be there i
was some new ideas were needed okay so i
started to think of new ideas involving
nuclear technology
the government would then go off and
patent it now feynman says this is
insane
he'll be talking to them all day with
endless ideas of what he could do with a
nuclear reactor such as the type that he
was working on as part of the manhattan
project
he could patent a nuclear submarine a
rocket an airplane in addition to the
bomb which of course they wouldn't let
him patent he claims in the book that he
wound up getting a patent for an
airplane in the rocket nowadays google
patents makes it incredibly easy to
search for patents going way way back
but as hard as you look you can't find
any patent issued to a richard feynman
and yet he describes it in such
painstaking detail he gets a call long
distance
where some military g-man wants to talk
to him they're going to develop a
nuclear-powered airplane and they say
his name is on the patent he has to
testify and sign off on it that he
transfers the technology to the military
i'm not taking your stuff okay the
government is he claims he got three
patents on obvious things i think i got
three patents i don't know what they are
anymore three patents have my name on it
maybe he was mistaken it was certainly
something that could be patented and i
don't think he would make the whole
story up but it seems odd the
painstaking detail he goes into such as
receiving a dollar from some military
guy which he then uses to buy chocolate
chip cookies for everybody in the
laboratory and why would he make such a
thing up maybe the patents were
actually granted but his name was taken
off or never issued to him
maybe he was considered so much of a
pain because of his exploits cracking
safes and being a curious character and
a wise guy at los alamos that the
government didn't think he was the
trustworthy steward of such advanced
technological applications the way the
patent process works is often a little
bit hard to understand they're
interesting to get your intellectual
output out there but most scientists
would rather publish a paper and give a
talk or give a presentation rather than
actually get expectation of some
monetary windfall from their patents now
it turns out you can find a richard
feynman with numerous patents in google
patent search except there's a name in
front of it carl carl richard feynman so
there is a richard feynman with multiple
patents but it's richard feynman's son
carl not the elder fund and the nobel
laureate we compare this to einstein
einstein had many patents including
refrigerators electromagnetic pumps
sound reproduction devices and light
intensity self-adjusting cameras he did
so much that it's hard to think of
einstein as a mere theoretical physicist
so was feynman jealous you be the judge
was feynman fibbing seems to be
contradictory with principles did his
memories linger and grow or was he maybe
just jealous of his old buddy albert
einstein now i turn it over to you
which patent of fineman's do you wish
actually existed maybe a nuclear-powered
rocket or two leave a comment below and
don't forget to visit my website
briankeating.com to subscribe to my
twice monthly email list